alo bị mất hình à Ô alo
không ạ
Alo
[âm nhạc]
Ờ không biết bạn
đấy có phải là người hay tương tác không
chắc là có
Ờ hôm nay vẫn là một ngày kiểu tâm sự có
tâm sự nốt mọi thứ có thể đúng không ạ
Tâm sự nốt cái mấy cái này
ờ nhìn trông bên này m ít
hơn và hôm nay mình có bảo là mình sẽ
kiểu các bạn cần xem hết qua mấy cái này
trước xong rồi mình sẽ ngồi xóa một loạt
đi thì chắc là Ừ chắc là ít
sau đó thì mình sẽ buổi sau mình sẽ cố
kiểu nói chung là tâm sự hết ngày hôm
nay Xong rồi trả lời mấy câu hỏi các thứ
xong rồi buổi sau mình
sẽ chia sẻ đống này xong rồi lý tưởng
nữa thì buổi sau nữa thì sẽ
Ừ kiểu mình lại quay lại ngồi code
code các bạn như các bạn đã thấy thì tôi
đã ngồi cài vết code và tôi sẵn sàng
ngồi code rồi đúng không ạ Ờ nói chung
là tôi cảm thấy là năm mới mọi thứ đều
mới bao gồm việc là
à đấy thì thay đổi thêm cả góc nhìn con
người cứ thứ thứ mình sẽ ngồi thử code
những cái điều mới những cái
kiểu nó cũng nó cũng đương nhên là tạo
hôm trước thì sế tôi C bảo là em thích
làm khó bản thân mình à kiểu thế khi mà
muốn thử code cái kiểu Alo à đầu tiên là
mấy ông nghe rõ không thôi hôm nay chỉnh
mic nhạy hơn một tí không biết mấy ông
có nghe rõ không Alo Alo
bảo là mic bị nhạy quá nhạy quá kiểu
dạng là thu được cả tiếng bên ngoài tạp
âm bên ngoài nên là tôi hôm nay chỉnh
mic nó bớt nhạy hơn thì không biết nó có
nó có kiểu nghe được
không Ok có nghe rõ đúng không ạ
à Thế được thì sếp Tôi có bảo là kiểu Em
thích làm khó bản thân mình à Kiểu Tại
sao không mua con m đơn giản kiểu dễ
dùng vẽo cái dùng đỡ phải cài đặt lăng
nhăng kiểu phức tạp các thứ bởi vì
Windows Phải công nhận là lâu lắm Quay
lại win ấy cài mất một ngày liền vẫn
chưa xong tôi không biết tôi chia sẻ mấy
ông chưa Hôm trước tôi nhớ Tôi có kể
Hình như là có rồi đó là tôi
cài tự l cài Win còn bị lỗi đấy Xong rồi
xong rồi lại phải mang ra hàng để nhề
người ta cài Bởi vì lúc mà tôi cài Hình
như là bị thiếu Driver à thiếu Driver
tùm lum à Đấy Xong rồi tải trên mạng về
C bị thiếu thiếu Driver kiểu không Ngay
cả cái việc mà kết nối mạng wii nó không
có driver để mà mở wifi có thể mở lên để
kết nối mạng ấy thì đôi biết là thiếu
như nào rồi
đấy rõ ràng là tôi tải từ nguồn uy tín
Nói chung Hôm đấy mất cả một buổi để
ngồi sửa đấy Sau đó thì
mang ra hàng may người ta cũng cài lại
nhan nhanh đấy nhưng là bản tự như là
bản crack các thứ đấy Xong rồi à Mất một
ngày hơn một ngày để ngồi cài các phần
mềm các thứ
rồi dùng kiểu cũng vẫn chưa thực sự
thoải mái Uầy tôi mới dùng vs code được
một tí thôi à nhắc mà nhớ tôi sẽ phải mở
lại một vài extension đây
lên ơ lộ COD lỗ code Chắc không sao đâu
Chắc chưa ai nhìn thấy gì đâu chẳng sao
đâu
cái ex này đi bởi vì kiểu đại khái
là đại khái mà ông cứ hiểu là kiểu
Tôi Tôi định đi dạy cho sinh viên thì
tôi không muốn là kiểu dạng
là nó gợi ý Ví dụ kiểu tôi có copilot ấy
nó gợi ý tận răng
tận răng các thứ thứ cho thì sinh viên
nhìn thấy kểu sinh viên bắt trước theo
là một nữa cả sinh viên sẽ sẽ kểu không
học code mấy đúng không Nhưng mà tôi
nghĩ đi nghĩ đi nghĩ lại có khi là ngồi
mở lên cho cho mấy mấy xem cũng là một
cái lợi the kiểu bởi vì nó cũng kích
thích kiểu sự t mò vì nó thằng là tôi
dạy ở trường
nghề cho mấy em đấy lại là mấy
em
à Hôm qua tôi mới đi dạy nếu ông nào
chưa biết thì hôm qua tôi mới đi dạy bên
m hoa dành cho lớp kiểu marketing nên
thành ra là kiểu mấy em đấy Kiểu học
công nghệ thông tin lập trình các thứ
như này nó chỉ là một cái kiểu một
cái kiểu thêm một cái lựa chọn cho em ấy
thôi tiếng Anh kiểu optional ấy có một
cái lựa chọn nữa thôi chứ không phải là
cái mấu chốt cái kiểu
cái cân thiết nên thành ra nhiều em kiểu
học cho có không nhận Lâu lắm mới quay
lại đi dậy th nh là khản dọng V trưởng
ngày hôm qua hôm qua tôi về khn đọng cực
Mai nhất định là tôi sẽ Phả đi đi mua
cái máy chợ giả kiểu Nếu không biết thì
mua cái máy trợ giảng là cái gì Nó là
kiểu cái mic kiểu có thể đo đeo cổ hoặc
là gài áo hoặc là cầm cái mic xong rồi
Nói thì nó sẽ
nó sẽ ra phát ra từ cái loa
đấy chứ hôm qua tôi thường nói kiểu gần
như là liên
tục 4 tiếng sáng rồi 4 tiếng chiều khản
giọng s CN kiểu đôi khi phải nói to hơn
bình thường một tí bởi vì kiểu lớp ồn ấy
thì mình phải nói to hơn tí để cho add
đi không lại được 40 cái mồm mấy không ạ
chịu xong rồi à công nhận là lâu không
đi dậy Quay lại cái
sự tôi nhớ lại cái vụ nói thẳng luôn đi
dậy tôi cảm thấy nó nhàn chán Nhàn chán
hơn so với đi làm đi làm tôi thoải mái
linh hoạt hơn rất rất nhiều à kiểu dạng
là ít nhất là giờ dấp thoải mái hơn là
một thứ hai mình thể làm Nói chung là
mọi thứ mình muốn kiểu dạng đi làm tôi
cảm thấy ít nhất là tôi đi làm rất là vu
vu Thể Thứ nhất là môi trường này xếp
cũng vui thoải mái này xong mình cũng
làm được việc nói chung là rất vui Còn
đi Dậy
thì kiểu Khi mà gặp nhiều sinh viên là
kiểu lời học xong rồi Kiểu Ít ra là sinh
viên của tôi Tôi chưa gặp trường hợp nào
chống đối bao giờ nhưng mà kiểu nhiều
bạn là đi học cho bố mẹ vui ý nhều mà
bạn học để nói chung là vì rất nhiều Do
không phải vì lý do muốn học kiểu thế
nên là thành ra là nó ảnh hưởng đến tâm
trạng mình thật tôi nghĩ là tôi cố tìm
một một vài niềm vui khi mà đi dậy và
chắc chắn là chú ý là vì sinh viên chứ
không phải vì cá nhân vì vì cá nhân thì
tôi nghĩa là tôi đi làm tôi thấy đánh
giá vui hơn còn đi Dậy
thì tôi cảm thấy là hồi trước tôi nể tôi
vãi trưởng Tôi không biết tôi kể cho mấy
ông trưa chứ hồi mà tôi đi dậy hồi mà
lúc mà tôi mờ ra trường thì tôi được mời
ở lại dậy Hồi đấy tôi dậy kiểu đã có
thời kiểu dạy kiểu cầy trâu vãi trưởng
đây nhá m ông cứ hình dung
nh tôi bắt đầu dậy bắt đầu dậy nhá ca
dậy là từ 8:00 sáng đến 12 gi trưa xong
rồi 13 lại bắt đầu Dy tiếp đến 53 xong
rồi 63 lại Dy đến 93
từ thứ hai đến thứ bảy ngày nào cũng như
thế
Ờ Và đôi khi ở cả chủ nhật Nếu mà à học
sinh có thi thì sẽ thi được Chủ nhật về
hết giáo viên để mà chấm thi hay trông
thi vào các ngày khác rồi
đấy mấy ông ấy sẽ thấy là kiểu
Ui làm việc kiểu hợc bơ thế trong một
khoảng thời gian các thứ tôi cái hồi mà
tôi được lên làm trường bộ môn ấy là bởi
vì tôi
à Bởi vì tôi kiểu đứng lớp quá lâu kiểu
cũng quá nhiều ấy nhiều hơn cả một người
bình thường đứng nên chỉ sau 2 năm là
tôi được lên làm trưng bộ môn vì đứng và
được dạy lớp kiểu nâng cao hơn nữa đấy
vì đứng đứng quá nhiều và đôi khi là
phải chạy hai lớp C lúc đươ nhiên là tôi
dạy thế chắc chắn tôi khẳng định luôn là
bởi vì tính cách của tôi không phải vì
vật chất nên là tôi mà không phải dạy vì
sĩ viên thì tôi cũng chẳng biết trả lời
à lý do tại sao tôi có thể hợp bơ được
như thế
cao hơn anh Ờ tôi khẳng định được nó tùy
bởi vì cái hồi trước tôi dạy ở trường
Đấy là trường tư nên
là nên là
kiểu nói chung là trả lương mọi thứ nó
sẽ sẽ được nhỉnh hơn so bình thường so
với trường Bình trường công vì rõ ràng
mà là học phí của sinh viên cao hơn bình
thường mà nên là lương mình cũng sẽ cao
hơn Hồi đấy tôi nhớ là hồi mà tôi hợp
bơi như thế đã có thời điểm tôi hơn 30
Bây giờ ông cứ hình dung nhá mới ra
trường kiểu kiểu cả ông lên mức xio chưa
chắc là lương ông hơn được 30 đúng không
ạ Đây vừa nói chung là kiếm được Hồi đấy
kiếm được như thế và cũng có địa vị các
thứ các thứ nge oà đấy nhưng mà tôi vẫn
đụng phát Tôi vẫn bỏ bởi vì tôi cảm thấy
là tuổi trẻ mình vẫn nên ra ngoài va
chạm Mà công nhận là cũng kiểu dạy thế
Đúng kiểu vì sinh viên chứ chứ mình cũng
gọi nh phá sức ấy
và mình không Mình không kiểu gọi như là
củng cố được thêm nhiều kiến thức chuyên
môn chỉ cùng lắm là kiến thức sự phạm
vởi nói đi nói lại vài cái thì mình biết
cái Dậy thôi chứ còn kiến thức của mình
nói đi đi nó lại cái cơ bản và toàn
những cái mình biết rồi thì kiến thức
mình cà càm bị may một dần đi
win nhưng mà máy tôi hiện tại có vẻ khá
ngon mượt Tôi cảm thấy là so sánh con
hiện tại với con m không khác biệt lắm
đúng mai tôi sẽ mua một cái con phù hợp
để cho phòng kiểu 40 50 người đại thử
nói xem thế nào Giờ anh đi dậy à rồi làm
công ty song song hay chỉ tập trung đi
dậy anh nói chung là bì bất đắc dĩ đi
dậy thôi vì bên trường thiếu người kiểu
thầy mời anh về để mà hỗ trợ nên anh xin
nghỉ vào thứ Tư hàng tuần để anh làm bù
và lúc khác nó cũng là một ngày giữa
tuần nên thực ra nó cũng may mà sắp xếp
được công việc cũng xem được xếp là sẽ
cố sắp xếp công việc các thứ
nó nói chung là
ờ thứ nhất là sếp tôi khá là linh linh
động để tạo rất nhiều điều kiện cho anh
em cũng như là mình bản thân mình cũng
phải đi kèm với trách nhiệm các thứ các
thứ ví dụ hôm nay là tôi lên công ty vẫn
làm được khá nhiều việc thôi tôi đạt kpi
Hôm nay ngày cuối của tháng LC quan là
hôm nay ngày cuối chứ tháng này mà 28
ngày có khi là là tôi không đạt được kpi
tháng này tất nhiên là tháng này thì do
là nghỉ Tết rồi rất nhiều yếu tố nhưng
đại khái thì hôm nay một loạt tt của tôi
thì kéo sang đă nên là đang từ kiểu mình
đang chưa đủ chỉ tiêu kiểu mình hôm qua
mình chỉ 20 ph chỉ tiêu kpi hôm này lên
Hàn một trăm bốn mấy chị phần trăm rồi
thì mấy ông lúc đấy mới biết được hôm
nay tôi được kéo rất nhiều kiểu bởi vì
những cái t những cái nghiệp vụ từ tận
tháng trước tôi ngồi làm làm nhiều Cực
đấy thì hôm nay được đánh kiểu kiểu được
đánh hoàn thành liên tục thành ra vượ
vượt chỉ tiêu rồi đâ Lại yên tâm thoải
mái rồi
đấy Nói chung là mình luôn thể hiện được
cái
kiểu kiểu gọi là phó Độ à Nói chung là
giữ được giữ được phóng độ các thứ thứ
thì
C sẽ vẫn cảm thấy là mình vẫn làm được
việc vẫn tạo điều kiện cho mình không
ảnh hưởng công việc
anh có giống lúc đi làm không
ạ Anh thấy rất
nhiều rất nhiều nơi thực tập không khác
gì đ làm cả bởi vì à Trừ khi em phải vào
một cái doanh nghiệp lớn những cái công
ty kiểu tập đoàn các thứ các thứ nó nó
sẽ có hẳn một bộ phận riêng để đào tạo
về về cái thực tập chứ thực ra thường là
công ty nào cũng kiểu giao em tài liệu x
rồi Em bắt tay vào làm như một cái nhân
viên bình thường đôi khi có một vài công
ty là kiểu sẽ cho em vào hẳn dự án thực
tế để làm thử một vài tính năng luôn
đương nhiên là đương nhiên là em chưa
chưa đủ quyền cũng như là chưa đủ chính
độ để mà vào những cái tính năng khó
nhưng mà em vẫn sẽ được làm những tính
năng cơ bản các th thứ Nói chung là kpi
Đạt mức thấp rồi các thứ các thứ thôi
nhưng mà nói chung là bởi vì như anh vừa
bảo là họ không có người nên là thứ nhất
là không có người giám sát em nên là nên
là nói chung là đối xử với em như một
nhân viên bình thường thôi nghĩa là giao
em một cái một cái chi tiêu một cái api
nào đó để em hoàn thành xong rồi Có gì
em tự Báo cáo lại chứ không có ai kiểu
giám sát để đốc thúc hay là nhắc nhở Hay
là kiểu hỗ trợ cho em được nhiều cùm lắm
em phải tự vận động hỏi và họ thực ra là
em hỏi cũng phải hỏi khéo bởi vì không
phải là ai cũng có nghĩa vụ phải trả lời
cho em vì rõ ràng là họ được trả lương
để họ làm công việc của họ chứ không
phải họ được trả lương để giúp đỡ em chỉ
có leader thì may ra là họ được trả
lương để có nghĩa vụ là bao hết mọi thứ
nhưng mà chính vì họ bao hết mọi thứ Nên
là họ cũng dồn rất nhiều thứ để làm nên
là em cũng không có thời gian để hỏi
được leader em chỉ có thể hỏi được người
xung quanh đúng không ạ thì à Ờ nói
chung là kể cả đi làm hay đi thực tập
thì em vẫn cần có kiểu cái cái đầu mở
mang Để luôn sẵn sàng hỏi nhưng mà mình
phải hỏi sao cho nó gọi là ồn ồn tí
không thì không thì kiểu các nhân viên
khác cũng khó chịu với việc ngày nào
cũng phải đi hỗ trợ giải đáp cho một đứa
nào đó đúng không
ạ đi thập tị đi thực tập có bị mất tiền
không á không em thế nên là
đôi khi còn được phụ cấp thế nên là tính
ra là mình gọi là gần như mình đi học
đấy rõ ràng là mình rõ ràng là mình đi
không làm được việc nhưng mà cảm thấy là
mình mình lại gọi
nhỉ Mình lại đi học rồi đúng không
ạ Người ta kiểu phải dạy cho mình các
thứ thứ mình được học miễn phí ở đấy Nên
là thành ra là tôi thấy là việc đi HC
tập mình vẫn nên rất là trân trọng Uầy
Cái này chói vãi chưa Đổi sang cái này
chói
cái cái Display g
nhỉ Sao mình chưa tải nhỉ
f à đâ
lắc f lắ f ch
không như này tốt đ mắt này máy Win máy
Win thì cài được cái này còn m thì tôi
chưa Cải thấy dịu hơn không đấy vừa nãy
Vừa rồi mở cái màn hình chói kinh khủng
này Ừ tôi thể đỡ hơn rồi
đấy Cái này nó sẽ chiêu Định thay đổi độ
độ sáng của màn hình Nói chung là nó
thêm ánh sáng vàng cho dịu cho mắt và nó
còn căn chỉnh theo kiểu hoàng hôn ha
bình minh của cái cái theo cái l cây trầ
của ông nên thành ra là kiểu khá phù hợp
đấy săn này liên quan đến kiểu thời gian
trong ngày nó đều chỉnh độ độ dịu của m
màn hình lại chứ chói quá Không hề tốt
cho mắt đúng không
cái Ờ gì nh
cái đèn ở trên cái
Ờ màn hình nữa cũng để cho dịu lại nói
chung là tôi đấy thì tôi từng chia sẻ
mấy ông rồi đó là may bây giờ mình có
một tí điều kiện để mình quan tâm hơn
đến sức khỏe của bản thân Bây giờ giả sử
là mình không có tiền thì mình muốn quan
tâm nó chẳng làm được gì cả Chịu đấy nó
nan áo giống như hôm trước tôi có tâm sự
với đứa bạn Nếu mà không có tiền thì
mình chỉ bao gồm việc là mình gọi là vận
động kiểu rèn luyện sức khỏe được thôi
thôi chứ còn đặc biệt ở thành phố ấy chứ
Chứ thứ nhất là các bạn sẽ hít thở không
khí nó nói thẳng luôn l nhiễm thứ hai là
uống nước có thể không đảm bảo với a gì
nhở
Ờ ăn uống thì thì nếu mà ông không có
điều kiện thì thực ra ông ăn uống sẽ nói
thẳng luôn ăn uống đồ uống không đảm bảo
không chất
lượng kiểu dạng là an toàn các thứ các
thứ kể cả ông bảo là có thể mua về tự
trồng luôn ông Chắc gì ông mua được cái
nguồn đảm bảo rồi ông có tưới cái nước ô
nhiễm uổi đấy Nên nói chung là phải thực
sự là có có điều kiện thì thì ông mới
gọi là sống khỏe mạnh được có thể sống
có khể mạnh được ở ít nhất là ở thành
phố còn ở nông thôn thì tự ông tự ông
chồng tự ông ăn thì tôi không biết thế
nào nhưng mà hôm trước bạn tôi cũng nói
là thực ra ở nông thôn mà mình không có
điều kiện để mà
lọc nước các thứ thì nước ở đây cũng ô
nhiễm các thứ Nói chung là bây giờ con
người đi đến đâu nó cũng cũng kiểu dạng
là có thể gây ô nhiễm bên đấy nên là
mình vẫn phải đấy đầu tư mấy cái máy lọc
này lọc không khí này lọc nước này ít
nhất là cơ bản như thế chẳng hạn đấy nó
đã gọi là cứ cho là gọi là có điều kiện
để mà để mà kiểu hỗ trợ cho đời nâng cao
thêm đời sống rồi đúng không
ạ
như nào Tìm kiếm các thứ mấy bạn kia nói
đây tôi có playlist để mà dạy qua lập
trình cơ bản Nếu mà bạn bạn xem thử qua
cái máy video Đầu Để bạn xem cảm thấy
phù hợp hay không đấy phù hợp ở đây bao
gồm việc là
nghe được th hành được chứ không bị buôn
ngủ quá thì ông thể theo và tham khảo
nên từ nhiều nguồn khác nữa thì càn tốt
nghĩa là chúng ta học một lúc có thể
nhiều kênh một lúc được mà Nhưng mà mình
vẫn làm bài tập đầy đủ các th thứ để mà
cải thiện
đỏng trai anh à n đòng chai thì nó cũng
nó cũng gọi là
tôi không thể nói là nước nóng chay nó
là không sạch được nhưng mà ý tôi là
kiểu nhất Thì đấy nó cũng là kiểu cũng
tốn kém ấy chứ tôn kém hơn việc ông kiểu
tự tự đua nước đúng không ạ Đấy chắc
chắn thứ hai đó là kiểu gọi
nh th nhất là nói thẳng luôn là tôi
không thể thích vị nước Đồng trai kể cả
kể cả nước mà cảm thấy ít vị nhất nhưng
mà tôi vẫn cảm thấy là ừ chắc mình quen
ốn lọc quen rồi nước kểu nước bình
thường quen rồi Và thứ hai
là Ừ nếu mà có điều kiện nữa thì một là
dùng hẳn nước Đông chai nước khoáng các
thứ thứ hai
là là hai là kiểu
à chính cái máy lọc nước của mình cũng
bổ sung thêm khoáng chất c thử
hoặc là tự chế Đúng rồi có thể tự chế
mấy cái quả lọc nhớ rồi trước là tôi học
cái hồi sinh học cũng có cái vụ là kiểu
đi qua mấy cái tầng lớp lớp gì gì đó Lọc
ra nước ý đấy chơi cái trò tự chế đấy
cũng
không biết kênh Phú trị là kênh
nào nếu mà em nói bên discord thì anh
chịu anh không th không tham gia bên
nước nào ngon uống như nào máy thế Mình
không đề cập gì V bán nước ở đây
Ờ mấy cái này ông xem mấy ông xem rồi
đúng không Tôi coi như là mấy ông xem
rồi nhá Để tôi xóa đi nhá Tôi định kiểu
Xem x ngồi tâm sự gì đó nhưng tôi nghĩ
là nó quá dài ngồi xem hết tất cả đúng
ngy tôi sẽ coi như tất cả mấy ông xem
hết rồi coi như là tôi để đây để chia sẻ
cho mấy ông xem thôi chứ tôi cũng ngại
cho mấy ông xem lại rồi nhắc lại lắm coi
như ạ nhưng
mà tôi tôi có nhớ qua là kiểu mấy cái
này đều chia sẻ mấy cái thứ mà Một là
tôi đã nói rồi hai nó cũng thay đổi
cái thay đổi cái góc nhìn của tôi để tôi
dần tôi sẽ nói tôi sẽ kiểu nói na ná
giống như một cái video này
à
Ok
tiếp nên code giáo sư phức tạp hay đơn
giản à Tại sao tự nhiên tôi phải ghi
kiểu như này
à Tôi nhớ là cái lúc mà tôi
lên tôi lên văn phòng cũ kiểu gặp
mà kiểu dạng là bây giờ công ty tôi tách
làm dự án khác dự án mới mà Thì Có vài
anh em vẫn ở bên dự án cũ để tiếp tục
kiểu triển khai làm mấy cái code mà tôi
đã từng làm ở bên dựa ản cũ đấy thì lúc
mà tôi gặp anh em đấy thì anh em ấy bảo
ơ long giáo sư dừ Bởi vì anh em ấy bảo
là có bên danh đấy bởi vì cứ cái đoạn
cốt nào cảm thấy phức tạp nghiệp vụ các
thứ các thứ ở bên giữ ản cũ là y rằng là
có dấu răng của tôi đấy có hiển thị gip
l ngay bên cạnh tô đùng là kiểu thì team
nnl đấy Kiểu thế biết rồi được thằng
code cái đoạn này và gần như là kiểu đọc
hơi khó hiểu tôi tôi cũng biết được là
là tôi code ạ Đấy nó cũng phức tạp đương
nhiện có lý do của nó tôi không phải là
tự nhiên thích phức tạp hóa vấn đề lên
mà hồi đấy gọi như nà Hồi đấy là khi mà
code dự án đấy là bọn tôi vẫn theo tình
trạng
là nh là không có ai review code cả đấy
nên
nên là
kiểu mạnh hai người recode là một thứ
hai đó là
ờ mỗi người sẽ đảm nhận kiểu hẳn cái cái
cái tas đấy chứ không phải là nhiều
người cùng làm chung một cái task một
cái tính năng nên thành ra là kiểu ai
cũng Đàm nhận cái phần phần đấy và hiểu
cái phần code mình code thôi người động
vào đoạn code đây
thôi và tiếp theo là kiểu gọi nhở
à Có rất nhiều tính năng kiểu
à Gọi nhờ cũng ngợ non háo đá rất nhiều
cái nói chung là tính cách của tôi Thời
đấy cũng kiểu dạng là kiểu muốn làm cho
nó xịn cho nó ngầu à không phải cho nó
ngầu như Nói chung là làm cho nó
kiểu kiểu Dạ nhà không phải cho nó phức
tạp Đâu tôi dùng từ là như nà
nhỉ Cũng không phải làm cho nó khó hiểu
quá nhưng tôi hiểu được là đương nhiên
là tôi nhớ được tôi đã cốt cái gì chắc
chắn tôi vào Tôi sửa được không đến nỗi
như như như nhiều người là mình còn
chẳng nhớ là tại sao mình code cái đoạn
đấy Nhớ Lý do tôi code đoạn đấy Tại sao
nó phức tạp như thế và nói thẳng luôn
gốc dễ của vấn đề mọi thứ chỉ đơn giản
là mình chưa đủ trình để mà code nó
trông nó nó clean hơn mình chưa có đủ
tầm nhìn đủ tư duy để mình code clean
hơn thế thôi đ đấy Em chỉ là
kiểu mình mình chỉ đến cái ngưng là mình
code được thứ nhất là để C nó chạy được
thứ hai đó là bởi
vì cái đoạn đấy khó có thể làm đơn giản
hơn phải dùng từ khó í nhất là với tôi h
đấy nghĩa là đo đấy đầu tiên là tính
năng Ok tnh năng phc TP là một chuyn nhá
Nó cò li quan việc là tôi lu nghĩ bài
toán tối u th thành là mấy ông cứ hình
dung nhá điển hình nhất là thằng larel
luôn thằng larel có rất nó là Framework
rất là xịn nó hỗ trợ rất nhiều cái Điển
hình creation sim các thứ thứ để cho
khiến cho code trông kiểu nó hỗ trợ nận
răng rồi thì ông dùng các hàm của nó là
coi như là có thể làm code trông code
của ông trông khá là gọn đúng không ạ
nhưng mà bù lại thì thằng darel Chính vì
nó hỗ trợ thế nó rộng quá Như thế thành
ra là toàn bộ mấy cái kiểu mấy cái cái
hàm của nó nói thẳng luôn là nó nó chẳng
qua nó che dấu cái sự phức tạp ở trong
những cái hàm này thôi chứ trong hàm của
nó viết code thứ nhất là cũng phức tạp
chẳng qua mình không đọc cái cái co Cái
lõi của nó nên mình nghĩ mình kiểu che
đi vào những cái hàm đơn giản của nó thì
mình nghĩ là ở trông nó code nó clean
đấy Cái thứ nhất nên là cái thứ hai đó
là Chính vì code bên trong nó phức tạp
nó xử lý phức tạp thế nên thành ra nó bị
chạy chậm đấy nên thành ra là tôi khi mà
xem kiểu làm đôi khi là tôi không dùng
những cái có sẵn được như thế nó na ná
giống như là kiểu m ông Hình dung là
kiểu ra Script với Zig ở một điển hình
đấy về sau rất nhiều người là không
chuyển không Chuyển qua không dùng J
dùng cái thư viện khổng lồ cái thứ thế
nữa bởi vì cải cả thư viện khổng lồ ấy
về code để chỉ dùng những cái hàm của nó
đôi khi ở Thà mình tự code nó còn ngắn
gọn hơn và nó còn nhanh hơn bởi vì vì
cài thêm cả thư viện đấy về Ừ dùng những
cái hàm nó trông ngắn gọn trông ngầu ấy
V cả nó khá là nặng đúng không ạ thằng
lel nó cũng giống thế thôi Thực ra thằng
ạo cũng sẽ kiểu như thế nghĩa nó có
những cái hàm trông vẻ gọn Thế nên thực
ra nó xử lý nó phức tạp hơn làm cho nó
nặng hơn đấy thế nên là tôi lại thường
hay làm những cái tas liên quan đến tối
ưu liên quan cả database các thứ thứ Nên
là thành ra là tôi sẽ code kiểu tôi sẽ
code kiểu làm sao cho nó hiệu năng nhất
có thể đấy Nên là nên là code đấy tính
ra kiểu nó sẽ bị kiểu mình hiểu được cái
đoạn đấy thôi ý chứ còn giống như anh
Bình gần đây tôi có có kiểu có chỉ tôi
cách
code đó là đôi khi chúng ta phải chấp
nhận là code thứ nhất là ngoài việc
không nói việc code dễ đọc đâu nhá chỉ
cần anh ấy bảo là tư duy đơn giản của
việc đó là em diễn giả diễn giải
không Nghĩa là đấy em phải đọc à Đọc bài
toán xuôi sao cho kiểu thế nào nó hợp lý
kiểu giống như là kiểu ông dùng mã giả
để mà Để mà giải quyết bài toán ấy sau
đó thì mới code nghĩa là em sẽ dựa vào
những cái đấy để mà code đng nhiên là
clean code đấy là một cách clean code và
đương nhiên là có thể hiệu năng nó cũng
sẽ không bằng cái code ban đầu vì nó
không tối ưu gì mấy nhưng mà nhưng mà
clean code ơn khá là
hay tự ông nghĩ là cần optimize ông thực
ra ông hỏi một câu khá là hay câu trả
lời sẽ là nửa có nửa không Nghĩa là thứ
nhất thì tôi đúng là tôi làm gì Bây giờ
tôi cũng thường hay nghĩ việc Là tối ưu
các thứ các thứ nên đôi khi mình nghĩ
tối ưu một cách thái quá đôi khi có nh
nhiều cái th cũng chẳng tối ưu hơn đứ
mấy nên thành code nó phức tạp hơn nhưng
mà cái thứ hai thì như tôi vừa nói
là đúng là có một vài chỗ là tôi đã từng
code nó khá là clean Nhưng kiểu mình tận
dụng hết triệt để mấy cái hàm larel nhìn
trống kiểu ngắn gọn xúc tích các thứ thứ
Ui trông trông kiểu tầm chục dòng giải
quyết được bài toán rồi đấy nhưng về sau
chính tôi cũng phải vào để mà sửa cái
đoạn đấy bởi vì À nó liên quan đến hiệu
năng mình cần phải cải hiện đấy nên là
nó sẽ là có lúc thì đúng là mình là phức
tạp h mình tự nhiên này mình lại nghĩ
nghĩ kiểu xa quá mình lại đi tối ưu cái
đấy nhưng mà cũng có những cái chỗ đúng
là phải tối ưu thật
đấy hôm nay tôi cũng nói chuyện thế với
sếp tôi với anh Bình thôi đó là là em
không
à em không suy nghĩ giống anh đấy thì do
chúng ta có thể fix được bức của nhau đy
Nghĩa là nghĩa là
kiểu anh anh đấy có suy nghĩ kiểu kiểu
khác đ nh khác mình nhưng buột lại thì
mình sẽ nhìn được những cái nhược điểm
của anh đấy và buột lại anh đấy sẽ nhìn
được những nhc điểm của mình nên là tôi
thấy thực ra nó không hẳn là một cái gì
đó
Kiểu kiểu à gọi như là là một cái điểm
xấu quá lớn một điểm khác biệt quá lớn
trong vấn đề C miệng sao là cả hai đều
vẫn cốt được C thứ thứ nhưng mà đương
nhiên là mình cũng phải thay đổi dần góc
nhìn đó là cái đoạn nào cần nên làm và
đoạn nào không Bởi vì đôi khi đôi khi
đấy giống như ông vừa
nói là kiểu Nghĩ xa quá nghĩ kiểu nĩ
phức tạp hóa quá lại khiến
cho cái trường hợp mà nó không xảy ra
bao giờ
à Ừ có ông em ở đây nữa ông em thì
thường hay code ngắn gọn quá anh thì à
cá nhân anh thì anh thấy là kiểu anh
không biết dùng em dùng màn hình gì nữa
nhưng mà cá nhân anh Anh thích kiểu nhìn
code nó trông tường minh và clean hơn
Nói chung là anh
thì gọi là chia sẻ đương nhiên là góc
nhìn của một cái ông thường ai làm đi
tối ưu nên thường ai nghĩ phức tạp đôi
khi phức tạp hóa vấn đề lên nên là làm
code nó hơi bị kiểu cứ cố tính
kiểu
à lên đến cái tầm code lúc nào cũng
clean lúc nào cũng kiểu
Ờ lúc nào cũng kiểu làm cho mọi thứ nó
đơn giản đỡ phức tạp để cho về sau sửa
nó
thứ thứ Thực ra là mình còn chuẩn là
mình phải chuẩn như xế Tôi bảo là thực
ra mình còn phải chia chia ra như cái
layer có những cái layer nó chỉ xử lý
bài toán nghiệp vụ cái layer nó nó chỉ
liên quan đến việc lấy ra data các th
thứ thì mình mình chỉ optimize những cái
nào kiểu gọi như là mình có thể optimize
cái phần layer lấy data chẳng hạn giả sự
Thế còn cái phần layer xử lý nghiệp vụ
thì mình vẫn nên viết sao cho nó kiểu
rất dễ hiểu để người ta để người người
nói thẳng luôn là người không có chuyên
môn người ta đọc cái code đấy bằng tiếng
Anh mà nó sao cho nó giải cảm thấy là
đọc được xuôi bài toán cũng được
đấy Không kiểu gì cũng sẽ bị chửi thi
BN chất là kể cả cho dù ông code Tôi cảm
thấy là thế kể cả ông code thế nào nữa
ông vào tôi cảm thấy là tôi vào cả mấy
cái repo của kiểu mấy repo lớn openc ấy
thường trong đấy thường được đánh giá gỗ
xị Tuy nhiên vài đoạn thì tấm tắc hen
nhưng mà có nhiều đoạn thì mình cảm thấy
là kiểu nó cũng có cái độ phức tạp của
nó thôi và lẫn cả là nó không xử lý gọi
là nh xử lý quá nhiều bài toán nghiệp vụ
phức tạp trong đấy Nên là thành ra là
khó khó để cân bằng cái đấy thật Nói
chung là tôi chưa đến cái ngưỡng đấy thì
mình mình cũng mới chỉ gọi là mới nhận
mình chỉ mức đến gọi là tôi cảm thấy gần
đây tôi mới chạm đến ngưỡng ngưỡng đầu
của xio nó liên quan đến kiểu Dạ nh liên
quan
đến đấy hướng đến sự đơn giản và Cin
code dần chứ còn nếu mà chỉ làm được làm
được code thì đúng là chỉ mức Junio th
Tôi nghĩ vẫn làm được code được rồi
luôn code mọi thứ đơn giản dễ hiểu mà
xịn được lúc đấy Chả Master mất
rồi
à tiếp theo là Podcast đi anh ơi
ờ ừ chắc về sau nế có thời gian sẽ làm
cái đấy nếu mà nếu mà
kiểu
một là livestream như này hai B cạm được
tùy không biết tôi thích kiểu tương tác
kiểu này vui
chity setting phân dài trong app l tố
ban ngày ban đêm không biết được nó có
trả lời được chuẩn hay không nhưng mà
mình cái thấy cái nào dịu thì mình cài
thôi mếu có thấy màn hình tôi vàng hơn
không ạ Hay là do mỗi mình tôi nhìn thấy
tôi không biết được
đâu anh đi làm được mấy năm rồi ạ đi làm
hơn 3 năm rồi Nếu mà làm bên ngoài đương
nhiên là hồi trước đi Dậy thì cũng tự
mình ngồi mò làm cái dự án web cho
trường nên là nó cũng không biết được
tính hay không Nói chung là code cũng
khá Nếu mà bắt đầu code thì cũng khá lâu
rồi
Ờ hôm trước hôm trước
tôi có đi sửa điện
thoại gọi là hôm trước nhưng mà cái lần
mình ghi cái này này chắc là phải từ 3 4
tháng trước rồi thì sửa điện thoại sửa
đồ công nghệ Nói chung ấy đặc biệt tôi
chia sẻ với mấy ông bởi vì về tất nhiên
là vẫn về tư cách là góc nhìn Của Một
Thằng Dân công nghệ thì
à À đợi đợi đợi tôi đợi tôi một tí nhá 1
phút m
công nghệ thì khi mà mình đi sửa cái gì
đó mấy ông biết mình cần lại làm gì
không
ạ
Nó chỉ đơn giản là mình
à Tôi khuyên Nói chung là hạn chế để mà
Thứ nhất là mình có Mặt trực tiếp ởo đấy
nếu mà giả sử nhưng mà đương nhiên Mình
bận mình không nên dành thời gian các
thử thứ đấy còn không Mình sẽ phải tìm
cách kiểu tháo hổ cứng à Đấy trong
trường hợp
là máy tính nhá Nhưng mà tháo hổ cứng ra
mà ông động và tem bảo hành phiền đấy
hoặc là nhờ người ta ở đây tháo hộ để
mình cầm mang về Nói chung là toàn bộ dữ
liệu Ý tôi là toàn bộ dữ liệu của mình
cá nhân của mình mình nên bảo mật nó
mình tránh việc là cái người sửa của ông
cho ông không thì có thể là họ có thể họ
không động vào các thứ thứ đâu nhưng mà
nhưng mà ở đấy có rất nhiều người đúng
không ạ thậm chí là nh đùng phát máy
cũng mất bị đánh mất hay gì gì đó rất
nhiều yếu tố đúng không ạ nên là tôi
không tin tưởng được ai cả nên là cái
hồi mà sửa điện thoại đấy Tôi cũng thế
sửa điện thoại này Thực ra tôi chỉ thấy
pin thôi nhưng mà tôi không có thời gian
ở đấy và tôi muốn để họ kiểm tra qua mọi
thứ khác nữa nên nên là tôi cài lại máy
các thứ đương nhiên là tôi cũng chưa làm
mấy cái kiểu phức tạp hơn tôi nghĩ là
cái máy Chắc là ở đấy chắc là cũng họ
cũng không tay máy đế nỗi là họ chạy cái
phần mềm gì đó Khôi phục lại dữ liệu
nhưng mà chuẩn là mấy ông có thể cài vài
phần mềm về đó để mà chắc chắn là nó sẽ
không thể khôi phục lại được dữ liệu cái
vụ khôi phục lại dữ liệu ấy thì nếu mà
Mấy ông nào chưa biết tôi tôi nhớ Tôi
nhớ Tôi đọc và như thế
nhá nói chung là toàn toàn bộ những ký
thức tôi chia sẻ với ông mấy ông thì đều
là những cái thứ tôi từng đọc được nguồn
nguồn n là trên mạng chứ không phải
nguồn ch me pro đâu nhưng mà nhưng mà
đại khái thì không biết là nó lỗi thời
rồi hay Vân Vân Như nào Không biết mấy
ông cứ có gì thấy sai copy nhá Thì đại
khái thì theo như tôi nhớ
thì
không hoàn toàn đương nhiên nó vẫn xóa
nó vẫn giải phóng bộ nhớ nhưng mà không
có nghĩa là nó sẽ không thể khôi phục
lại được bản chất là xóa cái gì đó gọi
kiểu à ố cứng ý Thì đại khái là nó chỉ
là cho phép dữ liệu mới có thể ghi đè
lên vào cái vùng nhớ của dữ liệu cũ chứ
bản chất là dữ liệu cũ nó vẫn còn ở đây
đấy nghĩa là ông hoàn toàn có thể khôi
phục lại được hết kiểu các thứ thứ được
đấy nên
là SSD thì nó cũng thế
thôi Nên là thành ra là ờ đại khái
[âm nhạc]
thì ông nếu mà ông xóa thù công các thứ
thứ kể cả cả lại máy luôn thì gần như là
nó vẫn thể khôi phục được thấy nên là
ừ cách tốt để mà cách tốt thì giống như
tôi vừa nói đó là bản chất Xóa đi là để
cho cái thằng khác nó GH đè lên vào cái
vùng đấy đúng không ạ thì cách tốt đó là
ông phải tải một vài cái phần mềm gì đó
về đầu tiên ông xóa h đi này x Tải cái
phần mềm ấy về nó sẽ ghi ghi lin ta tin
ghi đè lên chính những cái bộ nhớ cũ đấy
những cái vùng nhớ địa chỉ cũ đấy Xong
rồi nó lại xóa đi một lượt nữa thì coi
như là nếu người nào khôi phục thì chỉ
khôi phục lại toàn m cái link ta tin kia
thôi chứ không thể khôi phục được cái
gốc cái lúc đầu dữ liệu gốc của mấy ông
có được đấy
thì tôi biết là cách đấy thì nó mới
chuẩn là người khác không thể động được
gì vào dữ liệu của ông đấy Đấy là theo
lý thuyết hồi trước tôi đọc được chứ tôi
không biết bây giờ nó công nghệ nó xịn
như nào
rồi À còn phải nhiều lần nữa ừ đấy Nói
chung là cũng cũng phải nói chung không
phải gì
đó Chắc là nhiều lúc thì mình sẽ cũng
hơi bị ngại một tí mình nghĩ thôi cho dữ
liệu mình chẳng gì quan trọng đâu hay là
hay
là cha không rơi vào tay thằng nào đâu
Nhưng mà không biết được đúng không ạ
Không biết
được tôi vẫn đang nghĩ là có thể dữ liệu
nhạy cảm tôi đang ở trên máy một ông nào
đó đang đợi thời Vì sao tống tiền mình
à không bây giờ nó còn Phả liên quan đến
mắt mình nữa giả sử mắt mắt mình mắt
mình khác mắt người bình thường mình có
giống người bình thường đâu
được á Hồi trước là anh có một cái SH ấy
anh có đăng đúng một SH duy nhất bởi vì
hồi trước nhờ một bạn kiểu gần như là
cộng tác viên bạn ấy hỗ trợ anh kiểu cắt
một cái só của một video để mà đăng lên
ý thấy bạn ấy làm hiệu ứng các thứ thứ
kiểu giống kiểu cắp cắt giật giật ấy vui
phết nhưng mà bây giờ không có thời gian
không Bạn ấy cũng bận và anh không thời
gian để làm cũng như là không kiếm được
bạn nào làm rồi chẳng về sau bắt trước
bên COD m kểu Còn những bạn cậu ta viên
là sinh viên sinh viên được cái lợi thế
là họ chẳng họ nhiều nhất là năng kiểu
thời gian và cái sự năng lượng tích cực
h ha Mọi thứ rất xối nổi n nhờ vào mọi
thứ rất
tài liệu
á hủy Vật Lý Á hủy Vật lý Thực ra vẫn
vẫn có thể tìm cách khôi phục được
cho lời khuyên học tiếp larel hay Note
GS vậy em hướng theo gọi như tôi tôi
thấy cái vụ larel p với nots nó cạnh
tranh nhau nhiều chẳng biết khuyên gì
nhưng mà học mỗi cái nó sẽ cho mình thêm
cái góc nhìn khác nhau ấy nên là và hoàn
toàn thể học cái này có thể nhảy sang
cái kia tôi không nói là tôi sẽ nhảy
sang Note zs nế chắc chắn tôi sẽ học
sang những cái ngôn ngữ khác nữa nên tôi
cũng không quan trọng về ngôn ngữ bây
giờ nữa Cái này tôi cảm thấy nó C bị
vàng vàng ấ Đợi
quay lại đây nhỉ cáo
á
mà Ui chói quá chói
rồi
rồi nó vẫn giảm ạ
nhở
Sunset B time Thôi kệ đi không quan
trọng nhưng mà cái này nhìn tôi nhìn
thấy tối
thật sáng nhất tối nhất như này sáng
nhất này Ok thôi s giữ sáng nhất như
sửa
máy Ừ thưc ra là dùng máy tính thì vẫn
còn có nhiều cách nhưng mà dùng Điện
thoại tôi không biết được như th
nào anh có thể sa sành các chatbot
có khác biệt tương đối còn ba thì tôi
chưa dùng mấy cái kia cũng chưa Ờ n càng
không so sánh được cũng như là tôi nghĩa
là tôi không làm không có thời gian để
là ngồi làm kiểu cái thử thử để để so
sanh cá nhân tôi thì tôi bây giờ tôi gần
như dùng cái copilot này dùng dùng chity
này đ nhiên dùng cả gần đây dùng thêm cả
thằng này này cot preview này này như
thằng review này đều vãi trưở khẳng đị
đều vã trưởng hỏi mấy cái kiểu nó C trả
lời chắn đời của gì chẳng biết chắc chắn
nó không cùng copilot của giub tôi cảm
thấy thế hỏi về code nó chả trả lời chán
đời mà hơi buồn hơi tệ Ờ
tiếp một cái
nữa có cái hai cái cuối này nhá Hôm nay
thực ra tôi cũng chỉ định kiểu tâm sự
một tí trước khi
kiểu kiểu xong cũng không hẳn là tâm sự
tận hai tiếng như hôm
trước đây từ chính cái video này khiến
nó tôi tự nhiên có thêm động lực của mua
nhà không biết là mày không biết à đầu
tiên là tôi không biết từng chia sẻ mấy
ông chưa Thực ra tôi sinh ra lớn lên ở
Hà Nội nhưng mà thính ra không có nhà
riêng gì cả kiểu
và gia đình cũng không phải cũng thu hệ
hoàn cảnh nên là không không gọi là có
nhà cửa hay là gia tài gì đó để lại coi
như là tự lực cánh sinh mọi thứ thôi thì
à nh về sau tôi tôi không rõ là tôi kiểu
phải xông tiết kiệm nhà để mà để dành để
mà mua cái nhà hồi trước nghĩ thế cho
đến khi làm ở công ty này thì công nhận
là ít nhất là ở Đã ngộ công ty Bây giờ
tôi cảm thấy là Ừ tôi có thể tự tin nếu
mà sống tích góp T thì chắc là về sau
vẫn có thể mua được cái nhà nhưng mà bây
giờ lại bài toán đó là cân nhắc việc là
mua nhà ở mua nhà đất hay là mua nhà
trung cư đúng không ạ cái việc là tôi
còn đang nghĩ đến việc là tôi còn chưa
chắc là sẽ ổn định ở một chỗ vì tôi còn
đi dậy nữa tôi có thể là đi dậy ở Tôi có
thể có thậm chí là tôi nếu mà giả sử tôi
về B FPT không biết chia sẻ mấy ông trưa
hay là rồi nữa đó là nghĩa là là khi mà
về h ấy không hẳn về hillu đâu chước tầm
30 40 à 30 hơi quá Nhưng có thể 40 hoặc
đổi lên đại khá Đế có thể về dạy FPT
mình có thể chuyển vào mua nhà nhà gọi
là cũng là chung cư nhưng mà được hỗ trợ
h tr ở ở FPT ở trong Đà Nẵng đấy thì vào
đấy gọi là vào đấy cũng là để nghỉ nghỉ
Hill dần à Kiểu bởi vì à Đây kiểu vào
đây cho tôi cảm thấy là khi mà vào đây
cho đỡ s bồ ấy thì thấy là dân ở đấy Dân
dân ở đấy tôi tôi quen biết ấy thì hiện
tại hiện tại thôi rất là hiền và kiểu
kiểu Nói chung là ở đấy tôi cảm thấy
không x bồ như Hà Nội hay là Sài Gòn
kiểu thế không biết được cái lúc mà tôi
đến tầ đấy tuổi thì ở đấy nó sẽ thế nào
như tôi vẫn nhớ cái hồi mà tôi đấy cũng
lâu lắm
rồi thì dân dân đấy khá thân hiện hi
Hiển và còn tắt đè đi ngủ sớm mã chưởng
chẳng nhì sao 9 gi kiểu rất vắng nươ
nhên là có người đi lại nhưng mà kiểu cá
hàng quán đóng
dần đy thì nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy nó khá
Thanh Bình đ để mà
mình bớt phải va chạm các thứ các thứ
đúng không ạ Mình sẽ kiểu vào đấy
được Kiểu hồi đấy anh 9 giờ vào đấy Đi
chơi 9 gi K thấy các hàng quán đóng cửa
cùng lắm là chỉ có mỗi kiểu Club ba bụng
vẫn còn mở cả hàng quan nóng cửa hết ạ
có đúng mỗi tôi đi mãi Phố Mới tìm được
quán hàng nước cái hàng nước đấy cốt là
để mà bán cho dân hiếu kỳ ngồi xem cái
cầu cầu xoay ở
chỗ chỗ cạnh con sông
đấy x Cuối cùng thì tôi đã thấy nửa
à nửa đêm câu nó xoay xong hết
vị cứ ngồi để uống nước hóng CN cười sao
có ông nào đó lừa Hình như con rồng nó
còn khè lửa không biết là cái vụ đấy ở
Đà Nẵng hay ở đâu nữa mà tôi tôi Hồi đấy
tôi cũng chưa biết không thì chớ có khi
tôi cũng phải đi hỏng cái vụ ấy
hẳn là ý định là thích hẳn tiền để mua
nhà à cũng lắm phải đi thuê rồi về sao
tỉnh kiểu nói chung là khi lập gia đình
đ nhiên mình phải suy nghĩ rất nhiều cái
như tôi nghĩ sẽ đi thuê gì gì đó cho đến
khi xem cái video
này xin phép mở ạ xem video này xin phép
mở ạ à không phải video này ạ Xin lỗi
ạ Ơ không phải video này luôn Ơ thế tôi
chưa ghim lại video đấy như thôi ôm sao
Thôi nói đại ý của video đấy đại khá chỉ
giả một ông ngồi hát hết dễ đã ý ông ấy
hát như ông hát ở nhà Vừ cái giàn loa
hay phải chưa đy
kiểu kiểu giàn loa kiểu xịn K việc mic
bắt thờ
thử cá nhân tôi là người th hát nên tôi
Thực ra tôi chưa Giờ tự có suy nghĩ là
kiểu mình sẽ
kiểu có một dàn Coke kiểu như thế chọ đ
khi xem cái video đấy cảm thấy Uầy về
xong mình muốn muốn cánh gian và H cok
kiểu thế đấy Tôi nghĩ là kiểu nghĩ
ngay lập tức nghĩ ngay đó là mình sẽ
quyết tâm
à Mua nhà đất và ở của ngoại thành để để
có có thể có lắp dàn loa kiểu như thế
bởi V Tính ra nhà chung cư ông lắp dà
loa thế m nà cách ông không thể đủ để mà
ông thể thoải mái được và tôi tính tôi
là một người rất
ngại rất ngại kiểu ảnh gây ảnh hưởng
xung quanh hàng xóm mọi thứ kiểu rất
ngại ảnh gây ảnh hưởng tế ngồn ấy nên là
tôi sẽ nghĩa đây nên phải ngoại thành
một tí để mà mình có thể Tứ nhiên là
mình vẫn lắp cách âm các thứ thứ nhá đấy
nhưng mà mình vẫn gọi đại khái là mình
có thể thoải mái các thứ thứ nhưng mế
không hiểu Tôi không chiến giả TH thôi
Ui có mục tiêu to lớn vã chưa Tôi thể
ngày nào tôi hát được nên thành ra tôi
nghĩ là tôi cần có cái g loa kiểu thế
chến giả thế thôi Đấy thê một cái nộ lực
to to lớn và lúc đấy tôi lập tức nghĩ
ngay đến tôi ở Hà Nội nên là tôi lập tức
nghĩ ngay cái ước mơ Hồi bé không phải
ước mơ hồi bé đâu mà hồi bé tôi lại suy
nghĩ nghĩ đấy Đó là nói thẳng luôn là
mua nhà trên phố cộ bạn biết rất là đắt
Mà đúng không ạ thì không B có ý tưởng ý
định mua nhà trên phố cổ hồi bé đã nghĩ
ngay V việc Nếu giả sử mình vẫn muốn lên
phố mua nhà ở đâu Cho kiểu vẫn tiện lên
phố nhỉ thì chỉ đơn giản là qua Gia Lâm
đấy Qua Gia Lâm qua Long Biên đấy thế
Hồi đấy tôi ý định là sẽ mua nhà bên Gia
Lâm Long Biên ngay từ hồi cấp hai cơ Tôi
đã nghĩ thế rồi nhưng đương nhiên hồi
đấy làm gì có tiền Còn bây giờ thì ít ra
có tiền không một tí
th đất đắt phải trưởng cũng đang chưa
biết thế nào nhưng mà tôi vẫn có ý định
thế nếu có thể nếu có thể nếu mà lý
tưởng nhất ấy
đấy Đúng rồi Tuy là cứ ngồi chơi nơi đấy
nơi khỉ ho nhưng thực ra Tính ra tôi anh
vẫn anh vẫn định đ đầu tư vên đấy Từ hồi
trước rồi nhưng anh vẫn chê nhá Bởi vì
đi qua cầu nó luôn là một cái phạm trủ
gì
ạ m không biết khái niệm kiểu free ship
nội thành trừ cứ qua cầu là mặc định
tính phim
kiểu làm quả đôi ghế giống Bay Phượng
Múa đồ gỗ á Hay như
chắc đấy là trước lâu rồi Đúng rồi Hồi
mà tôi vào Đà Nẵng lâu lắm rồi ấ Hồi đấy
là mới ra phone iPhone 7 hay iPhone 8 gì
đấy Tôi vẫn nhớ là cái việc là tôi có ấn
tượng kiểu dân này th thân thiện và kiểu
thân thiện và kiểu thật thà như nào Hồi
đấy gia đình tôi đi taxi Ờ cái anh anh
tôi kiểu hồi đy có cái con iPhone vừa
mới ra kiểu đã sắm rồi rồi rời h hai lần
ở trên taxi ạ và hai lần người ta Tổng
đài đều gọi liên hệ kiểu để mà trả lại
các thứ các thứ lúc đấy mới thấy thần
thiện mọi thứ tốt
viên này cả bạn bè ở đây có tôi vẫn nghĩ
định là trong năm nay năm ngoái thì đã
đã định như không được trong năm n kiểu
gì tôi cũng sẽ vào đây thì tôi sẽ vào
Quê nội tôi ở Quảng Trị nữa tôi sẽ đi
tàu vào đấy Lần đầu tiên tôi đi tàu cũng
là vào Đà Nẵng và đấy là lần
kiểu lần duy nhất thì lần thứ hai tôi
vẫn sẽ cố đi tàu để vào Đà Nẵng và vào
và vào cản trị các thứ thứ thế để lại
trải nghiệm lại trải nghiệm lần đầu tiên
đi tàu đấy cũng vui phết đi vào gia đình
mọi thứ và tôi cảm thấy là gọi nhờ số
tôi đúng là vẫn có tí Số đào hoa mỗi là
đi du lịch ha rằng là y ra có một bạn nữ
sinh sinh nào đó đi cùng kiểu bạn bạn bè
à Bạn của à Con của bạn mẹ đấy hoặc là
gì gì đó Nói chung toàn tầm tuổi đi cùng
nên cũng có động lực vui
chuyến anh em kiểu đi cà phê
xong FBI gì Ủa Alo tâm tuổi tôi mà nó
trông là kiểu kiểu
à cho dù lúc đấy mình bé thì th ra mấy
bạn đấy bé tầm tuổi mình
tốt rất nhiều lý do để khiến nó tốt
Tôi chỉ nhớ cái quả C nhất thôi đó là
đấy Đúng rồi Tôi nhớ chính xác rồi Hồi
đấy là tôi 16 tuổi đấy bé kia 15 tuổi
đấy rồi như nào nhỉ t tôi cay quả đấy Đó
là h tôi đi cùng thằng bạn
à đi đấy thì mình đi tàu xong mình cứ
nằm kiểu nằm cái giường tầng ấy rồi nằm
giường tầng ở trên cùng tôi với thằng
bạn tôi nằm ở giường tầng trên cùng thì
ngó đầu xuống là em đấy năm ở Ngà tầng
thứ hai ô kiểu Mê vậy chư tôi m kiểu năm
năm V thằng B ngon xuống em đấy là muốn
ngủ hoặc làm gì h khác các thử thử mình
thì thằng chỉ là một thằng mọt sách sim
thử không biết làm gì khác lướt Facebook
chẳng có gì nhặt nhẽo thôi k thôi nm đấy
h đấy cũng chỉ có Facebook thì cũng nm
gì có kiểu tiktok giải trí gì đó
Đấy rồi à Xong rồi bọn tôi hồi đấy được
ở khách sạn bốn sao phải B hay ba sao
không phải tôi nhớ HM đến nỗi năm sao
khách sạn Hoàng Anh Gia Lai xịn phết
được bao mà Đấy Nói chung là tôi cảm
thấy là cuộc đời tôi khá là may mắn kểu
đấy đương nhiên là không khá giả không
có điều kiện vẫn đúng nhưng mà Bởi vì
cũng quen được khá nhiều người để mà
thỉnh thoảng được đi những cái dịp mà
nói chung là cũng gần như đuổi đời ngĩa
đi được những cái dịp mà Nó là một cái
ngưỡng gì gì đó ấ
chị em thôi chứ Đấy thì dạ nhở đi khách
sạn đấy ok Mọi thứ rất là thích kiểu
cũng thoải mái cho đến khi cảm thấy
không thoải mái nữa Khi mà cả gia đình
Hồi hôm tối hôm đấy rủ nhau đi
à vũ trường à Kiểu vụ trướng được mệnh
danh là to nhất Đông Nam Á thôi đấy ở Đà
Nẵng không biết được có chém gió hay
không Tôi không tra đại khái cả gia đình
đều
đi mọi người đều đi Bọn tôi thì kiểu hai
hai bọn tôi kiểu mặt chả măng kiểu 16
tuổi N không đi được Kiểu thế đã thế còn
tôi hồi đấy còn bị kiểu mẹ soạn quần áo
cho toàn là quần đùi áo cốc tay trông
kểu chết con vãi trưởng không thể đi
được
đấy cho
đến cho
đến khi nhìn thấy bạn cái em 15 tuổi kia
em đế mặc kiểu vãi trưởng kiểu đúng kiểu
đy mình biết được mặc kiểu trông kiểu gi
dặn kiểu chừ hành cái thơ thứ ấ đấy em
mà đi được Kiểu cái
cay mẹ không hiểu cảu ra thấy không th
con trai 16 tuổi nhưng mà mặt vẫn bú và
sữa em gái 15 tuổi em m kiểu đi già qu
gót rồi diện diện các thứ Xong rồi xong
rồi Kiểu Nói chung là em đấy đi đi được
Chẳng ai hỏi gì cả đấy múc gì linh tinh
đây kênh Tuy kênh này cũng là 18 tuổi
cộng hết rồi an như mà chúng ta không
nói mấy cái chuyện nhạy cảm gì đó đây
và nói chung là chúng ta chỉ nên dừng
lại việc ngắm
thôi đại khái như thế
Ờ mình thì xong rồi Đã thế bởi vì là đươ
nhiên là cuộc đi chơi đấy của cũng đại
gia đình nên là cũng có trẻ con các thứ
thứ
là những cái những kẻ ông nào không đi
thì ở lại trong trẻ đấy Kiểu thế nghĩa
là có tôi với thằng bạn tôi c g đình đi
hết
ạ Ông anh tôi đi xong rồi còn về kể lại
chán lắm em ạ toàn toàn mấy bạn kiểu ăn
mặc khở hang nhả nhót chẳng có cái gì
dẫn chuyện kiểu gì tự nhiên sang câu
chuyện này
càng đi Đỡ hơn
mà có con anh ấy đi đi ở trong chuyền
đấy Đi luôn anh ấy anh ông anh đấy là
ông anh gần như là cũng gần như anh ruột
của tôi Anh ấy kiểu tính cách rất là lạc
quan thoải mái Tôi cảm thấy rất khó để
mà khiến anh ấy giận được ấy cho đến khi
mà thấy anh ấy dạy con đúng Anh ấy có
một cái kiểu đương nhiên là khi làm bố
mẹ thì kiểu khi ông nói chuyện với con
cái ông sẽ kiểu phải nghiêm túc ấy anh
ấy Vương nghiêm túc quát con
xong vẫn quay lại nói chuyện vui vẻ mình
được lúc đấy Lần đầu tiên tôi thấy anh
ấy quát ai đó trong đời luôn ấy vì tính
anh đấy kểu lạc quan thoải mái cực rất
là vui tính ấy r thứ thứ ấy lúc này tôi
mới biết Ui anh Ông anh mình có nhiều
lúc nghiêm túc các thứ thế anh ấy hơn
tôi rất là nhiều tuổi hơn phải S bảy
tuổi gì đấy nhưng mà thấy anh ấy kiểu
vui vẻ là quan thoải mái cực ý đúng kiểu
Bộ trưởng Bộ Ngoại Goo ấy đi nói chuyện
được với cả trẻ con nói chuyện V cả
người lớn tiếp rượu người lớn nói chung
mọi thứ rất là ổn hai hước C thử thử ai
cũng kiểu ai cũng kiểu rất là quý anh
đấy và anh đấy là một con người kiểu
sống tôi kiểu đơn giản tối giản nên thấy
mọi người cũng thấy rất là quý anh ấy
nữa Lúc mà anh ấy đi cái quả chuyến đi
chơi đấy lúc rồi anh không bịnh đi Anh
đang nằm ngủ ở nhà Cho dù cả gia đình
bao gồm cả gia đình anh đấy cũng đi rồi
Kiểu chuẩn bị xong hết rồi
xôi tôi phải lên gọi anh đấy lúc anh
đang ngáy ngủ xo Anh bảo X này nhỉ mãi
anh ấy mới đi xu cuố cùng anh ấy đi lúc
mà tôi lúc lúc mà tôi bảo Ơ thế anh
không chuẩn bị gì à cầ gì chuẩn bị em
đấy C thử thử anh ấy mặc đúng bộ một bộ
qu nào ấy anh
đi
không chuẩn bị một cái gì luôn ạ cả sạc
điện thoại không bằng đi anh mà mỗi cái
điện thoại đấy Cái con iPhone 7 đấy đấy
Xong rồi còn rơi hai lần taxi ấ kiểu
không quan tâm vật chất luôn ấ không
quan tâm thử
thử đúng kiểu không phải xách ba lô lên
mà đi đâu xách cái thân lên mà đi kiểu
thế tr vì anh ấy mang đúng một bộ quần
áo đấy nên thành ra kiểu cứ tối đến anh
ấy phải C hết ra anh ấy giặt r phơi cười
vãi chưởng
nghĩa là tôi thì được được mẹ dắp quầ áo
cho nhưng mà toàn là toàn là kiểu áo áo
cọc tay với con đùi con anh đấy thì có
áo dài tay còn dài nhưng chỉ đúng một bộ
ấy thôi Đúng một
phong trần rất là quan như
thế tính cách của anh đấy anh cảm Tôi
cảm thấy là nói chung là có nét rất
nhiều nét giống Xuân Bắc kiểu thế kiểu
con người hài hước kiểu thế duyên rất
duyên
và rất khéo cũng như
là đấy
thì không để ý những cái kiểu gì đó kiểu
dạng là thực dụng hay mọi thứ Nói chuyện
mọi thứ kiểu đối đãi mọi thứ tư tế thế
Nhưng một người Hồi trước tôi khá ngưỡng
mộ cho đến khi kh à các bạn nhá Thôi tôi
không nhắc mặt tối anh ấy
này nhưng mà nhưng mà tôi chưa Tôi chưa
bắt tay vào làm nên là tôi không chưa
chia sẻ được mấy
ông nên là Nhưng mà nó cũng gần giống
với cái này tôi xin phép Kể câu chuyện
khác thì à Giống như tôi Vừ nói là tôi
không phải kiểu con người xuất thân
không phải có điều kiện lắm thì à thực
ra là tôi thường hay đã cố hạn chế Tuy
là kể về câu chuyện của đời mình nhưng
mà hạn chế kể về mấy cái gia cảnh các
thử thử n tôi phải chia sẻ Thật là hồi
trước là tôi ở trên phố cổ kiểu dạng là
nó khá mấy ông nghe phố cổ Nghe MC oi C
thử thử nhưng không kiểu nó Cái nhà nó
rất
là ẩm thấp bé tí bởi vì Hồi đấy tôi và
tôi không nhạc thì tôi sẽ ở với ông nhà
của ông bà ấy Nó kiểu bé âm thấp C thứ
thứ tôi ở trên các Sép nên thành ra nó
sẽ bị kiểu Thứ nhất là tôi không có
phòng riêng thứ hai là không không phòng
riêng đúng nghĩa là ông thay đồ người
khác ở dưới có thể nhìn thấy hết v chưng
thứ hai là
ờ cái XP thì nó trần nó rất là thấp nên
thành là tôi đi luôc nà phải cúi đầu ấy
hồi mà lớn hơn một tí là co như phải đi
cúi
đầu học một cách rất là tốt để mà bây
giờ đi ra ngoài không dám ngử mặt lên
trời kiể mặt cưng cưng đ B đậu cúi xuống
kiểu thế cũng hay để cho kiểu gọi nhể
mấy ông vơ được hay thế mà thườ nay được
mê tả như thế mà cúi đầu xuống không đi
ra ngoài đường kiểu mặt mà cng cng lên
tí mấy cái
đứa chắt nó nhìn thầy nó ghét nó đâm
nhau cái lại
mệt Không là qua là tôi không bị gù
nhưng mà đầu lúc là đi Hơi bị cúi cúm
xuống Tí vì cái trần đấy tính ra 1,7 m
đấy có khể không thì tôi sẽ cao hơn một
tí nữa tôi Bây giờ tôi muốn m 73 Nếu mà
giả sử không không bởi cái chân đấy tác
động thì chắc là có thể là tôi cao hơn
m73 nhưng là quan Tôi cảm thấy là chiều
cao của tôi bây giờ cũng gọi là không
đến nỗi thấp và cũng gọi là tương đối
không phải là cao không phải là cao
nhưng mà tương đối theo kiểu là gọi như
này tôi cảm thấy khá vừa đủ bởi Riêng
việc là bây giờ điển hình nhất là tôi
giờ nằm cái giường M8 bây giờ ở ở nhà
tôi cảm thấy là vươn chân lên một tí đã
chạm được đến cái thành rồi thì không
biết được
là mình mà à cao hơn nữa thì còn Sẽ như
nào sẽ khá phiền phức Tôi cảm thấy thế
nên nói chung là tôi hài lòng với cái
chiều cao hiện
tại nhưng mà hôm trước vừa nhìn thấy các
bạn nữ là nó chia sẻ bạn đấy một m 72 và
bạn đấy khó chịu với bạn nào bạn trai
nào mà lùn thì mình hơi tự
ti
nó lại quay lại câu chuyện đó là tôi
không có phòng riêng các thứ thử thế x
lúc mà lên đại học thìi ra Mình thuê
được một cái phòng gọi là phòng cũng
tương đối riêng nhưng mà nó nó vẫn kiểu
gọi là phòng chung với chủ ấ n nó không
có riêng tư gì cả Ờ chẳng qua mình thoát
ra khỏi cái cáp thô đấy mãi và lúc đi
làm lúc mà đi làm rồi thì tôi không kiếm
được tiền tôi không còn ở nhà của ông
nữa Cảm thấy tự do thoải mái hơn rất
nhiều Khi mà ra ngoài thuê nhà ở riêng
nhưng mà vẫn là ở chung với mẹ nên thành
ra vẫn không phòng diêng đấy bởi vì tính
ra thuê nhà khu tập thể cũ mấy không
biết kiểu nhà kiểu Họ thông nhau không
kiểu
phòng tôi để ra ban công chẳng hạn ý n
Thy ra phòng tôi luôn mở cửa chẳng không
gian gì cả đế bây giờ vẫn thế nên là cái
vụ mà tôi ghi cái nốt lại phòng riêng và
câu chuyện tự lập này tôi đang định là
tôi sẽ thuê hẳn một phòng riêng chính
mình
Ờ thuê ra ở riêng để mình hôm trước là
tôi thử qua thử phòng phóng riêng kiểu
dạng là công ty tôi ở Time City thì có
thuê nhà hỗ trợ thuê nhà ở cho anh em
thì thì tôi qua thử cái phòng đấy kiểu
tự nhiên cảm thấy có không gian riêng nó
nửa nó nửa vui nhưng mà nó cũng nửa kiểu
cô đơn
thật tính ra hồi trước mình không thực
sự ở riêng kiểu như thế nhưng mà tôi
nghĩ là tôi phải nên quen dần với việc
cô đơn đ Ai rồi cũng sẽ cô đơn Ai Rồi
đặc biệt con trai mình cũng nên quen dần
viới cô đơn Tôi nghĩ thế và mình cũng
phải tự lập dần mình phải quen dần V đi
mấy cái điều đấy đúng không
ạ Tôi chưa Ra ngoà ở riêng để tôi có thể
chia sẻ thêm cho mấy không thêm một gấc
nhìn nhưng mà nói chung là vì hoàn cảnh
vì rất nhiều yếu tố nên là bây giờ tôi
mới có điều kiện để có thể thực hiện cái
này tôi cảm thấy là tôi thực hiện điều
này nó hơi muộn so với bằng lứa bằng lứa
người ta kiểu ha gọi là 18 tuổi C có thể
ra kiểu dạng là sống ở sống tự lập các
thứ thứ V rồi còn mình mình Bây giờ mình
cứ cho mình 27 tuổi các thứ
thứ
à Nên là Ừ tôi cảm thấy là có nhiều cái
thì mình được ra ngoài đời va chạm sớm
hơn nhưng có nhiều cái thì về mặt tinh
thần này mọi thứ này thì mình có thể
mình thấy mình à đi sau các bạn
khác Nhưng mà không sao tôi nghĩ là bây
giờ vẫn đang trong giai đoạn mà tôi phát
triển bản thân theo kiểu là à về tinh
thần hay mọi thứ này Đấy Năm nay tôi cảm
thấy tôi sẽ cố phấn đấu năm nay là những
cái bước ngoặt trong cuộc đời của tôi
đấy về việc là chuyển qua code bằng vs
code
đấy rồi sử dụng Nói chung là làm rất
nhiều cái để cải thiện à Thêm bản thân
mình và tôi ít nhất là đến thời điểm
hiện tại tôi vẫn không ngại thay đổi
không ngại mấy cái điều đấy ừm
hi vọng là kiểu sau những cái kiểu chia
sẻ của tôi như này thì
à Thì mấy ông cũng có thể thấy được
là là
kiểu có những người kiểu dạng là nói
chung là tôi cũng không phải có là người
ta gì cả đúng không ạ Có những người
kiểu dằng là cũng có những cái khó khăn
họ Nhưng mà cái góc nhìn cái cách suy
nghĩ có thể tích cực lan tỏa cái sự tích
cực này đúng
không
tôi vẫn chưa Sẵn sàng vì đấy Cái tinh
thần tôi nghĩa là Thứ nhất là mình phải
tự lậm được tinh thần mọi thứ ổn định n
tôi vẫn tôi vẫn Hồi trước có đọc một cái
đó là đường vì cô đơn quá mà chọn nhầm
người Hay gì đó hoặc là kiểu
à chọn tình cảm yêu rồi giống như là
kiểu
à Lúc mà mình đang cô đơn Nó giống như
là kiểu ông
đi đi chợ với cái bụng đói ng ông thể
hoàn toàn chọn sai thứ mình cần thứ mình
muốn đấy tôi có nghe mấy cái thế thôi
nghe văn vở thế n tôi cố rồi Kiểu mình
không không bị thế đúng không Nói chung
là mình phải sẵn sàng là yêu đương thì
là một chuyện còn cưới thì với tôi nó là
một chuyện thiên niên khác n nó khá quan
trọng Làm sao để từ chối khéo khi có bạn
nữ tỏ tình với mình vậy
ạ Thực sự thì cá nhân tôi thì tôi không
biết là tôi Khéo với chắc tôi không giải
khéo với bạn nữ đâu Tôi cảm thấy tôi
khéo với bạn bè thôi còn một khi mà tôi
coi đấy bạn nữ đặc biệt là bạn người mà
mình cũng có tình cảm một tí tôi càng
cảm thấy mình không hề khéo nên là tôi
thường hay nói thẳng với người ta và
thường hay cứ chia sẻ thẳng thôi Bởi vì
tôi cảm thấy là giác quan của con gái
luôn nhạy để mà biết được mình sẽ nói gì
và nói thẳng luôn là đọc được tâm tư
tình cảm hay mọi thứ của ông ông không
thể nói dối được ý trừ khi ông phải nói
chung ông phải lên cái ngưỡng ở đó cứ
cho bắ boy để mà thể nói dỗi hay gì gì
đó để mà lươn hay gì gì đó còn không thì
mình là Good Boy thì mình chắc là Good
Boy đấy nhưng mà đại khái nó mình mình
không không thể lươn hay không thể nói
khéo được thì mình cứ nó mình chư chia
chia sẻ nói chuyện một cách thật lòng
thôi là bảo là là kiểu chia sẻ quan điểm
mình các thứ các thứ nói chung là
Ờ không có một cái lời gì có thể khiến
cho gọi là nó dễ dàng thì kiểu là bạn ấy
sẽ không bị tổn thương hay gì cả kiểu gì
bạn cũng sẽ thấy buồn hay gì gì đó nhưng
mà nói chung là nên nói sao cho mà không
bị à một phát là kiểu ông bị chặn không
không phải là kiểu chúng ta không còn
nói chuyện với nhau hay mọi thứ
muốn như nào nữa ví dụ Giả sử ông không
muốn nó có gì đó kiểu ông muốn cái gì đó
kiểu dứt khoát thì ông dứt khoát luôn
còn nếu mà ông muốn theo kiểu là chúng
ta có thể làm bạn nó lại khác gì gì đó
đấy tùy của ông cái tôi không biết
khuyên kiểu gì chỉ khuyên thế là ông hãy
thành thật chẳng sao cả ông không khéo
được thì ông có thừ nhận là ông không
khéo không vấn đề gì
cả ế là xu hướng mà không tôi tôi tôi
cũng cân nhắc việc đấy nhưng mà tôi
không hẳn là muốn đi theo xu hướng ê đâu
ạ fwi à Không không fwi cái benefit cái
gì gì đó thì tôi xin chết ạ C lắm là
benefit theo kiểu là đôi bạn cùng tiến
chứ không phải benefit th kiểu là chỉ
tìm đến nhau lúc mà có nhu cầu Xong rồi
giải quyết nhu cầu xong thì thì kiểu bỏ
mặc thì không ổn bởi vì chúng ta bạn bè
với nhau chúng ta đã phải để ý cảm xúc
của nhau rồi chứ không phải
là kiểu coi nhau như một cái thú vui gì
đó Không như thế thì lại bất ổn
quá Ok hôm nay tôi định chỉ tâm sự mỏng
mỏng thế thôi toàn bộ những cái này sau
ngày hôm à Buổi sau tôi sẽ xóa hết đi
nên là nếu có thể Nếu có thể thì mấy ông
có thể xem qua để mà biết được tôi chia
sẻ một vài gì hay hay ho gì gì đó được
không ạ
Ờ Người Yêu Cũ ngỏ ý quay lại anh có
đồng ý không ạ
Ờ quan điểm này Thực ra là kiểu rất
nhiều người từng hỏi Ờ không phải hỏi
mình nhưng mà kiểu nó là quan điểm muôn
thủa nó là tôi thì tôi thường cũng đọc
một vài cái rồi và tôi có quan điểm đó
là
kiểu thì cái lý do để mấy ông quay lại
thì tôi không biết nhưng mà chắc chắn là
lý do ở chia tay thì mới tất cả đều biết
nên Ờ Nếu mà Lý do chia tay nó vẫn còn
tồ tả thì không lý do là quay lại thế
thôi Nếu mà Lý do chia tay không còn
nữa thì mình có thể cân nhắc
thế
thôi Ok tạm Hôm Nay Thế nhá Xin chào mấy
ông